well for many years leftist billionaire
George Soros has used as wealth to
remake our society American society
his latest area focuses criminal justice
from Texas to Philadelphia the state of
Virginia Soros has reportedly spent
millions of dollars backing candidates
for District Attorney for prosecutor
once elected these candidates have
tended to cash have ended cash bail
treated felonies like misdemeanors and
sometimes ignored some crimes entirely
in the city of Philadelphia for example
Soros back to Larry Krasner and the
murder rate there is the highest it has
been in a decade Krasner's main party
though was to get even softer on crime
bill McSwain is US Attorney for the
Eastern District of Pennsylvania and he
joins us tonight
mr. McSwain thanks very much for coming
on so it's remarkable in a democracy
that one man can have the ability to
remake our justice system but it sounds
to some extent that's what George Soros
is doing what are his priorities what
are his goals in doing this well first
of all I would say that I think in a lot
of ways Philadelphia is the laboratory
where this experiment in Soros funded
prosecutors is playing out and now the
returns are in to a certain extent Larry
crasner has been in office for about a
year and a half
funded by mr. Soros and we can look at
the data and we can see what has
happened to Philadelphia and as you said
homicides have skyrocketed shootings
have skyrocketed the worst kinds of
violent crime have really gone up and in
addition to that some of the low level
and the mid-level crimes have also gone
up but they aren't being reported and
the reason they're not being reported is
because the DA has said he's not going
to prosecute them so you have
statistically a bad situation that has
developed in Philadelphia but actually
the reality on the ground is even worse
than the statistics and what mr. Soros I
think wants to do is that he wants to
implement his radical agenda and he
realizes that he can't do that through
the
democratic process normally if you're
going to try to get criminal justice
reform you have to do it through the
legislature you have to get broad public
support for the kind of changes that you
want to want to institute he's taking
what I would describe as an illegitimate
anti-democratic shortcut by trying to
purchase da elections and then once the
DA is in place he or she doesn't enforce
the law and presto you've got criminal
justice reform I guess and I've
everything you said is absolutely right
and for those worried about the
hijacking of our democracy here's a
perfect example of it actually happening
but but quickly I'm just wondering who's
the winner in this if violent crime goes
up if more people are murdered why would
you want so-called reform of this kind
I think the winners in this story are
defendants unfortunately criminals are
the winners in this story and mr.
Krasner makes no bones about about this
he's not even pretending to be a
prosecutor he calls himself a public
defender with power so it's almost like
letting the Fox into the henhouse once
he's in he's trying to cause as much
havoc as possible
he has no background as a prosecutor he
has no interest in prosecution he has an
interest in sort of cramming down his a
radical Pro defendant ideology on
everyone else and the effects are just
horrifying horrifying hey thank you very
much I think I think people don't really
understand that agree to which George
Soros is successfully remaking this
country and and they should understand
that you're a thanks very much you're
welcome glad that you're raising
awareness about it yeah we're try and
you know Soros has effectively
intimidated people into not criticizing
him it's some kind of moral crime to
call this to public attention but it is
in the public's interest to know and so
we are anyway thank you very much great
to see you thank you talker